[拍手]
こんばんははみしお
です
え去年あ去年じゃないや何言ってんだ今年
の夏ぐらいにですねあやという自己物件
訳ありの物件に後輩と泊まりに行ったと
いう動画を出させていただいたんです
けれどもあの結いろんなことが起きまし
てあれ突然が強くなってきたのその動画で
結構明らかにおかしいような音がなったり
しておりましてちょっと今回やり残した
ことがあって再びあやの方に来ております
あ夏に出した動画ぜひ見てください概要欄
から見れますというわけで案内人の桐さん
よろしくお願いしますはいお願いしますお
願いしますお久しぶりです久しぶりすねて
言っても来たのまた最近ですよねはい実は
秋にも1回来てましていや3回目です3回
て1年でこの3回参加した方はいないし
ここに連続でこの短いスパンに3回来た
だってお客さんでもいないんだああ本当
ですかいや本物だなと思っていやいや
そんな本物ですいやほとになんだろうな
仕上がってるっていうかいやいや夏に1回
来たのとは別にはずみ社長の畑でも暗夜で
撮影させていただいて2回目そして今回で
3回目ということになるんですけれども
なんかいやすごいすあの色々ありましたね
いや色々ありました入られたというお話を
聞したんですけどもあま本当に8人のま
窃盗団みたいのがやば入って今も弁護士
挟んではいはいはいま色々話してるんでま
普通に犯罪者が8に入ったっていうその
怖いのニュアンスが変わってきてますね
ちょっとそうですねもう本当にその人要素
があるあるっていうのはずっと言ってたん
ですけどま実際こういうニュースになって
やっぱ本当に危ないんだなっていうのが
うんま世間にわーってなってまキャンセル
もね結構出たりしてあらそうなんですね
じゃ本格的に被害というか本格的にそっす
ねていうかやっぱニュースになったことで
なんか知名度がまたそのYouTubeと
か見ないテレビだけ見る方も万延を把握し
ちゃって逆に人がいっぱい来るようになっ
たあ逆にですかでそれが一般の人とかとか
じゃなく
てあのなんだろうなま本当に仕上がってる
人っていう
か
本問が来るんですちょっとなんだろうな
病気の人というか精神的なちょっと病気の
人とかがへえまここに来てまもの前に立っ
てたりとかマジすかとかあの1回入ってき
たんですよね中にか中入ってきちゃってで
これって
あのあの3日
前最近そう最近そうジーズデイズじゃない
ですか最近前入ってきてえ大丈夫すか僕
それいやだからすごい
タイムリーすぎるんであんまり
そのおすめはしないですけどいや先に言う
べきでしたねいやいやそうです
よ確かにそう来てしまった
ので安全に気をつつ今日もちょっとアの方
邪させてくださいよろしくお願いします
そうま霊的な意味でもはいあのなんかあの
事件が起きてからまちょっと悪化してると
いうかうんまリタイヤ率がま6割ぐらい
だったのがあの結局70%いります7割に
なっちゃってでほぼの人がも帰っちゃう
マジすかという状況なんすよ今ってどう
いう理由なんですかそれはうんあやっぱ
そうすね触られたって人が多いっす
ねきさん僕今日1人
ですいやあの前回と区別化しようと思って
前回のサーベていう後輩がいたんですけど
はい今回ちょっと1人でせてくださいって
言したんですけどちょっと今考えてます
そうす
ねまちょっとここで僕がしたのも悪いす
けどま1人はやめた方がいいすよいややり
ますやりますかいや本当に仕上がって
るっすねキさんは僕のチャンネルで出た1
本目の動画見られましたああ見ましたその
事前チェックというか音やばくなかった
ですかいや音やばかったすね2階で
ちゃんとドンドンって言ってたんですよ
何か
うんまなんか音が聞こえたって聞いた時
なんかたぬきかなって正直思ってたんです
けどあの動画で聞いた感じあれす
ねま人顔化けですねあのサイズはいやそう
なんですなんか小動物とかのトントンじゃ
なくて完全に人が踏みしめてるドンドン
だったんでましかもその1回ドンじゃなく
てまバンバンバンバンバンて転
でその後寝てる時まどんどんどんどんなっ
たんでまあれはね
うんまやばいすよねやばいです本当にうん
あれが起きたらリタイヤするような現象だ
しまリタイア案件なんですけどまそのまま
止まり続けたっていうそこもびっくりした
すねお2人がちょっとおかしくて僕た
おかしいすよねああの病院もやばくああ
オルゴールになったんすよ見まし
たはいおはようござい
ます朝
ですええええええあれやばかったよねいや
やばかったいや僕絶対行かないすあっちは
いやいや
さんですよ僕なんですけどというわけで
今日はちょっとアの方にお邪魔させて
いただいてるんですけれどもやりたいこと
がありましてクエストっていうアアの中で
ミッションっていうわけじゃないですけど
ちょっとこういうのやったらやばいんじゃ
ないかっていうのをききさんいくつか準備
していただいてると思うんですけどもああ
そうですねその中でこのYouTubeに
出せる範囲のああやつをちょっとやって
帰らしてください
今日1人
で1人で1人でやるんすかいやでも聞いて
ください方がいいですねエビデンスがあっ
てですねはいあの最近ギャル霊媒師さんて
いう霊媒師さんがいてその人に僕占って
もらったんですけどあのこれいけるらしい
すえいやいやい丈ですこういう声なんです
も大いやいやま聞いた上でもやめた方が
いいすけどねはいただそのやっぱり現象と
か音とかはやっぱ効いちゃうらしいんです
けどもあそれによってなんか自分が疲れる
とかなんかその悪いものを背負っちゃうっ
ていうことが普通の人より極端に少ないと
ああ霊的なので人生が壊れたりするような
ことはないいてことですか今のところは
ないとなんでもうそれを聞いてあのなんか
中車になったやつあるじゃないですか
クエストでやばすぎてあああ闇ですね
それってやってもいいですか
いやあま闇はまやめた方がいいすけどねま
ま基本的に禁止にしてるんでなるほど
なるほど
要は僕がもう関与できないんでなるほど
なるほどそのやった方がどうなったかって
いう話があるんでうんまそういう話聞いた
上でま自発的にやりたいっていうのであれ
ばま本当自己責任で自分で自己責任って
いうことですねそうすね僕が関与するって
いうのはちょっとできないキさん側でも
責任が取れないとそうすねま止まること
自体責任は取れないですそうですねこの足
を踏み入れた時点でそうですよそうなん
ですよそのお話も聞いた上でそのまやって
はいけない行為になってると思うんです
けどもできたら1人でやってみます本当に
1人すよね本当に1人です
ほ最近YouTube始めた方とかでいや
これからYouTubeがっつりやって
収益会まで頑張るぞっていうこの若い人の
この勢いでやるとかじゃなくて大ベテラン
の方がここまで体張っていや僕そなんか
おかし1人で止ま
るっていうのはいやほん
もの仕上がってる
人よねもう僕の言動力は興味でしかないの
ですごいでは中の方にきたいと思います
はいあんやあん
や悲聞こえたすよ悲聞こえますねめっちゃ
高い声聞こえ
[拍手]
ます当は聞こえる
か
2回聞こえたっすよねまなんなら僕らが車
止めてるとこすよねあこれ映さねあそっ
[拍手]
か誰か住んでますあこいや住んでないすわ
すでも絶対ど言ますてよ
今えサ聞こえたし聞こえましたた今完全に
えっとです
ねまた聞こえたまた聞た
まあのクエストやる前に怖いのでききさん
説明していただけると思うんですけどはい
一応カメラマンでサービだけ呼んでます
サービよろしくお願いしますお願いします
ただ本番クエスト始まるとサービもきき
さんも退場させるので本当に1人でやり
ますボクスと変るってことですよねサビ
さんあそうです1人で残れおります
いやいやもう怖いやべえこいつみたいな
感じになっちゃってるじゃないですかでも
やっぱあの霊媒霊媒寺さんに大丈夫っって
言われた一言が結構いやちょっとそれが
背中押されてます悪い方向に働いてないす
か背中押されすぎてないですか若干悪い
方向にっそうですよねなんかあの下身とか
一切してないではいあの全く何を来てるか
わかんないあ分かりました状態なんでま霊
的なものでも人間でもなんか起きたらすぐ
逃げました分かりまし
[音楽]
た着きまし
た僕も行った方がいいですもね何言ってる
んですかお願いします説明を
ください
[音楽]
何今
の何これ
何何何マジで何マジで何
あんま森からしない音するっす
ね風まなってるみたいな入りましょう
やばいああ最ます結構いい感じの精神状態
で来たのに一瞬で壊され
[拍手]
たこの
何
いやこっから入ってきたんですよえ3日前
マジすかこっから入ってきたんですよで
ガラガラっ
て明るいちょっと人だったらねもうシレ
ならんないん
でですね本ちょっと中止ましょう
[拍手]
はい
さ行きましょう
か帰りますか
はい邪魔し
ます
ます懐かし
せああの人形移動してるあそうなんすよ
こっち側に移動したんす
[音楽]
よ今なんか落とせんかったます
ガチガチどうしまし
た
ここちょっと開いてたんですけどねここ
このれいや開いてなかったですいや開いて
てたんすよこれがてたんですいやいや
いや開いてなかったよな開いてなかった
ですいや
て来てない
でしょ多分覚えてないでしょ前じゃ
人いないかもかねてちょっと説明とかじゃ
なくてぐるっと軽く回りますそうですね
一応前回の動画で1周この暗夜の場所の
説明をしてるんですけど一応軽く見回って
いこうと思いますあの安全確認も含めて
いきましょうか
そうあここ閉じちゃったんですかあそう
です
ここなんかすごい柔らかくなっちゃって畳
自体がうんうんだけど続いてはない
ですまだあるのか
これ瀬頭はもこれは持ってかなかったすね
セトひの水神さのやつさまこれも結局何な
のか今も分かってないですね
へえ遅くないすかいやまだわーンって言わ
んかったあお
あおちょっとこれぱる
あろどんえこれあ
えうわ2回きた
ないでもね2階
から待ってたかもしんないですねちょっと
いや
多分幽霊なんで大丈夫
ですこれ
あえてはじめさんが
ちょっと待ってきませんでした今聞こえ
たなんと
なく
おすごい聞こえるこれ
ちょっとこれは
車お
っどじゃさムじゃないじゃさんは
チャレンジャーじゃないです
チャレンジャーじゃない
ですほらほらほらほらほらマジでなんかい
ますよマジなんかいますようんなんか
いる
いやこれきつい毎回こんな感じなんですか
いやそんなことないっす
よだってもう精子持たなくて徐々に開催日
少なくしてっ
てもう週3が限界っていうこと気づいたん
ですよなんか大学生のバイトみたいな
スケジュール感じゃないですそうすなから
その毎回
あこれ聞こえるわ見ますよどうしましょう
どうしましょうどうしましょうまあ行き
ますかこれあてはじめさんはめ
さん行ってくないですあえてなんかまず
逃げますね
いやあのこれ絶対約束するんねこれ
ギミックとかじゃないんで本当にやばい時
はやばいんで分かりましたそん時は逃げ
ましょう
え毎回こんな感じですかいや本当にあの
こんななんか畑ここまでじゃない畑来た時
もなんか結局あんまり怒んなかったみたい
でやっぱこのピンキなんすよねああ
なるほどリクで動かしてたら毎回ね起きて
もおかしくないですけどちょっとお風呂と
トイレ見ません1回あのなんならこっち
から聞こえてる説もあるんで
あも何もいないすねも大丈夫そうです
うんトイレも度開けてみる
かよ大丈夫かなああ大丈夫
です
よ行き
ましょうきさん俺2個もクエストやったら
多分くばりますこれマジで
いや1人でっていないんじゃないですかね
YouTuber
ておい
ちょっとちょっとあのなんすかこの
オレンジで光ってるのえ普段光ってない
です光ってないす見えるれだオレンジ
っこれ外に誰かいるっす
よここ開きますよねいやこれ付けすぎて
開かないんですよ誰かいる
ね知らないライトあこっから覗くかそう
ですねちょっとね外のるライト照らしとき
ます
[音楽]
ああ
ちょっとちょもう
ちょっといやもう帰りたい
い切りちょっと僕もしますよそういうこと
やり合いになったら大変なことそうやめ
ましこれプロレスじゃないのでこれはした
誰か言いましたいや多分近所のあの畑荒さ
れた時の防犯カメラ自動で作うんうんあれ
が多分勝手についちゃっただけだと思い
ます勝手についたうんだって今消えてんの
あ本当だ本当
消勝手についたってこと
はしたことですえ闇するだけでもすごい
ですか1人でいやいや闇はやめた方が
いいっすだて闇やめ
た理由はあのやった方がそのピンポイント
に事故るんです
よでその事故もちょっと事故ったぶつけた
とかじゃなくてあのもう半身不随まで行く
ぐらいのま大事にあった人もいてでしかも
それの件数がもう56件続いたんでさすが
にやばいだろってうんでやった方だけなん
でよやったチーム全員じゃなくてやった方
だけ後日事故ってるんで後日
かだ
から
まあ
ものすごい仕事に影響出ます
よ
いえギャルレバさんが言ってたおかしいて
めちゃくちゃなんか安全というか問題ない
えそれは
嬉しいもう良くない方に働いてる1回その
検証も含めみたいなところであそうなん
ですかこれでもし僕に何かあった時は本当
に闇はもう立ち入り禁止にすべきだと思う
のであ確かにもう実験代みたいなあそう
ですね状態にななってくれるってことです
かはいももっとえだと呼んでくださいえ
いやいやいいですか呼んでじゃあはいお
願いしますいや嘘そう全角にしましょうか
ちょっと2回だけね行かないとです
ねあさお前はいお前お前これを倒したせい
でタイヤ取れたんだからなマジ
で何何何何何待ってお前お前何してんの何
してんのすっごいやばそうな絵倒したお前
何してんのちょっと待って最悪だいやいや
こち攻だよ
大丈夫ですかいや本当になんでまだ置いて
あるんすかなんで倒したら吐するですかし
たキになんか起きちゃうマジでこれ倒した
のがこの子でこの子が高速道路でタイヤ
パンクしたって本にきまして命の危険です
ガチの闇色なしで事故りしと僕初めて見た
すよでも弱いってことですか彼が比較的
じゃないすか行きますねじゃ安全確認行き
ます
うわストあるな
これこれ戦闘マジですねいや先頭と1番
後ろが一番怖いんです
よ2回本当気つけて
く
失礼しますお邪魔し
[音楽]
ますクールですねそうすか大丈夫そうです
よねうんいや一旦人的なのは
そうそうすそ開いてたんです開いてます
元々え
え開いてないすええ開いてたよな開いて
ましたいや開いてないでしょ開いてまし
いや開いてない昨日見た時開いてましたで
もいや昨日来たんすか
えこの街もこんなんでしたっけあこれ
あの抜けたんすよ勝手にえ最近ですかう
いつかな夏の終わりぐらいですかねにこれ
バーンて勝って抜けてま最初老朽化かなと
思ったんですけどボーンて抜けた後に
なんかちょっとどんどんどんどんみたいな
音がなってたんですよ天井裏
でそうで天井裏で鳴ってたからなんか
ひょっとしたらなんか歩いててボンて抜け
たのかなみたいなこの上ってことですね
ちょっと旦これ閉めてもいいはいお願いし
ますこの部屋だけは閉めておいて欲しい風
で開いちゃったんですかねああそれはあり
そうもす
あいやでもここ窓な
いっす外気圧とかでああうわあやばい
やばい部はこれはまそうすねこれ換金部屋
なんでちょっと動画で全貌ドラクそうす
なっちゃうんですけどここも閉めとき
ましょう人
はうそうな気がしております
うんどうし大丈夫そうですかいや大丈夫す
ねうん鍵もかかってるしあめさっきトンて
言ってましたけどねうんなんか2階
から聞こえた気もしたんですけど結局冬と
かあの動物とかあんま入ってこないんです
ようんうんうんうんやっぱ眠してるという
か家の中に入ってこないんで動物ではない
と思うんすけどねでさ前回マジで人だった
よねンマジで人でした
ああれは猫とは言えなかったすね本当にま
ちょっと1階に行きますか一旦ね今日の
目的地行きますかはいはいというわけで
なんか色々もうありましたけどそうすね
とりあえず人的な危なさは大丈夫そうあま
そうすねま中にははいなかったですねえ
クエストどうしよう
ちょっと
あのま話さ
なきゃいけない話があってはいまあの後に
ちょっと分かったことあるんですあのま
この
家ま事件が起きる前からま幽霊が出ると
言われてたんですよ
でまやっぱ元からなんかあったんだろうな
というのをずっと思っててがっつり調べて
てその戦時中に亡くなった人たちが
まとまって埋まってるとはいでまとまって
埋まって
てでなんかその数
が100人以上らしくて色々聞いたりして
あのどんどん詰めてっ
たら
なんかここの家の
土地全部
元々えこの区画というかこれ全部すだから
今ここの
下めっちゃ骨埋まってるん
ですま今日入るって言ってる井戸移動
すごい深くてあの要は骨とゼ距離なんすよ
ね深いんででコンクリで埋められてるじゃ
ないですか中途アパにあれも下手したら
あの掘ったら骨出てきちゃうから掘れない
ようにコンクリート入れてんです
よだからあのここの家
ってもうどうしようもないですよねうんま
要はここの家に出る例はまその換金事件の
こともそうですけど亡くなった方のま例が
出てるということが分かったていう話です
ねでこれ最近取れた写真があるんですよは
やばいこれ2階なんですけど
んこれ分かります
でパチンねなんか言ったす
ねこっちは防犯カメラないからあの音はし
ない
はずああこれ要はまがっつりあの人が浮い
てんですよねここに撮影者とかではない
ですか撮影者がこの映り方ってしないん
ですよ結局確にこの距離でマジすかこれ
しかもこれかなと思ったんすけど手あるん
すよねでこれ下半身ないじゃないですか
ほらうわあセフか近くの服見てほらない
これ手ない本当だでこれって要は下半身
ないんで下手したらその戦争系で失った人
は映っちゃったとかかもしれないですね
なんかそれ聞くとあの下半身付随とかの
事故の仕方もなんかちょっと関連性感じ
ちゃいますねあーあと明らかにそのなん
だろうなまちょっと特攻するみたいな
わあっていう声がこの家中に響き当たった
動画があるんですよこれ後日防犯カメラ見
て入ってたんですけどさは確かにあの違和
感ある音聞きましたけ声とかこっち多いと
立が
[音楽]
始まってがあから
ね今の確今のは確実にや今のじじ叫んでた
なんか叫今その辺のじじ
がうわすげえ何これこれ後で調べ
たらあの室内だったんすよえそっちの
カメラの方がもう通にでかい音で拾って
ですこういうのを全部あの知るとやっぱ
戦争系のあ例が出ててまそれに結局事件が
重なってる状態完全にこの家自体が例の
巣窟になってですもうあれですね家という
下というか土地がというかもう土地ですね
そうだからまあ
お無無無理ちょっと何何何なんでやこれ
なるやつです
[音楽]
か切り来たこれマジで仕込みじゃない出て
ください出てください
いや出
ましょう切しちょっと無理
かなが出ましょうか
長え出
[音楽]
ますいやこれ絶対
す
長え僕が出るですかお願いしますあのもし
なので
ちょ
はい
もしもしえ誰かいるっすもんえ絶対いいす
かだってガチャってなってな
あ切られた切られましたなりました今
プープー言って
ます本当だえマジで仕込みじゃないですか
き
さんいやでもこれはお化けじゃないでしょ
いたずらすよさすがにもうちょっと
タイミングがあもう本当にやばいどう
しよう俺やばい
やばいさんこれもう1回なったらコード
行きましょうか行きましょうかこんなん
だったらもうえ俺これどうしたないいや
ミート2になったら本当に無理かもここの
電話番号知ってる人って結局ここに書かれ
てるこれじゃないんでえどうやって分かる
んですかここの電話番号そもそもまあると
したらこっから自分の携帯に電話かけるし
たら自分の携帯にかかってきて電話番号か
あなるほどなるほどなるほど前も1回あっ
たんすよ電話なったことですかなんなら
あんやってここの映像をま防犯と冷所の
記録用で11時間ぐらい夜中ずっと生配信
うんしてるんですけどそん時になってたん
ですよね何回
かだから来た方がそれやったのかなと思っ
て防犯カメラ確認したんすよはい今までの
人たち全部長時間かげてし
たらその行為をしてる人が誰もいなかった
んですよねいやでもま人だと思うすけどね
いやさすがに人無理に人だと人とだとして
もタイミングおかしすぎるで動画的には
もうやらせばりやばさですけどやらせにし
てもベタすぎるっすよ
ね自分でさっきスマホでききさん取って
ながらめっちゃやらせっぽって思いながら
撮ってましたいや確かにおいしいけど心臓
に悪いなこれでも色入ってる時になったら
俺マジでえ発狂したらどうしましょうあけ
さんえっとはいあのクエストなんですけど
2個やると僕絶対精神持たないと思うんで
あ1個に絞らせていただきますあ
そうした方がいいと思います分持たない気
がしますでその1つ
をどうするんですかあのあれ見ます表と
いうかあいえもうあべ闇闇どすかはい
ちょっと禁止になってしまったドをやらせ
ていただきたいですもちろん自己責任で
そうすね僕から言えんのはまそのやった方
がやっぱ交通事故になってるっていうのは
霊云々じゃなくてま実際起きてることなん
でま本当に俺はクエストだとは思わない方
がいいすあのこっちが関与できないんで
自分から井戸に入って真にして待機し
てる
本物だと思った方がいいす
ねどうも本ですちなみに本来闇て何
何でしたっけいや本来はあのま15分
ぐらいすね
り本来ってま全員で車乗ってもうその1人
残してうんうん数km離れるんですよこの
家からで帰ってくるって感じなんで大体
15分ぐらいでやっぱ闇に入って今まで
あったのがま帰ってきたらあのま出身して
たんすよ井戸の中で嘘でしょ井戸の中で
出身してたんですよマジすかで井戸の中で
出身してたんでもうはしごとかを立てかけ
てこうやって人間がその出身してる人を
運ぶことできないんで普通にまレスキュー
ええ虫と呼んでこうやってあげるみたいな
でまその人その後目は覚したんですよ場所
移動してま夜間病行ってでなんか闇移動し
た入った時のその記憶自体ががそもそも
そこだけがっぽり見れてるっていう
うーんだから結局何が起きたかわかんない
状態でなんかその人も結局事故にあったん
ですよはいその後結構その立ち悪いのは
後日なんか起きるっていうま立ち悪いっす
よね人生に直接影響してくるもんなんで
相当リスキーですよ電話さっきなったす
けど多分人ですけどまいたずら80%
ぐらい人すけどま20%
ぐらいちょタイミングも良くなかったんで
ま霊的なあれの可能性もあるじゃないです
か正直結構ベタですけどまそういう電波的
なものでなんか起きてる可能性とかもある
んででこういうの頻繁に別に起きてるわけ
じゃないんでま色々考えた上でねやるか
やらないかもそこから考えた方がいいかも
しれないですねまやれんすもんねちょっと
考えしてくださいいやそうなんすか考える
んすか
なんか知らんけど泣きそうになってきまし
たうん帰りましょう
じゃあね帰り
ましょうま最速ですけど霊能力ある人に
言われること結構バラバラで最近言われた
のは本当にそういう霊感というか疲れる
要素がびっっくりするわないっていうのと
別の人に足が弱いってれたんですよなんで
その今聞いた感じ闇に入って下半身が結構
何か来たっていうああ事故のお話聞いて
結構ビビってる部分があるのと別の人に
なん守護霊がめちゃくちゃ強いって言われ
たんですよああめちゃくちゃ守護霊が強く
て守られてるから大丈夫っってった人もい
て多分いたずらだと思うんですけどうん
なんかそういう守護れってなんか危機を察
すると教えてくれるって聞いたんで
うその説10%あるなみたいなあま確かに
本当になんかすごい空想な話ですけどま
結構僕もそういう受けにくいからこそこれ
ができてるそうですオーナーとしてて言わ
れてるんですけどま他の人にはその9体も
ついちゃってるとえキさですかそうそう今
ですかいやもうついてると言われて僕滝行
やらされて冬にもうバンバンびたんですよ
えカパ入ってだから結構そのバラバラて
いうのもあるんでま本当全部正しいかも
しんないしまどれかが間違ってもしない
ですけどあまりにも背中をされてうん攻め
すぎると本当人生壊れる可能性も正直ある
んでうんいや本当そうですよねだその守護
霊うでねあの電話が鳴ってたとしたらだと
したらもう1回なると思うんすようんうん
あもうもう井戸に行こうとした時にもう
やめとけみたい
な
うん闇って途中で出たりしたらダメですか
も身の危険を感じたりしていやいやもう
ルールはないいっすあそうですねもう自己
的にやってるといや出れないっすよだって
はしご立てかけて入って結局僕らが抜いて
行かなきゃいけないんでこれ出る時サーベ
さんか僕がも1回1個だけいけないですよ
なるほどなるほど最初なんてあの蓋閉めて
ましたからねやばすぎる本当
にお腹鳴ったいや
違う
今ぐってなりませんでしたうんなんか
聞こえましたねええどうしよう俺本当に
やばい時なんかそういう聞き信号もらうん
ですよこんなこと言うとなんかキモいんで
あんまり言いたくないですけどいや全然
その感じからしたらどうすかいやちょっと
やめた方がいい感じあかり
ますうん正直あの電話がマジでキリきさん
言った通り80%いたずら20%そういう
可能性ぐらいのうんえもし闇でやっててあ
じゃあもう決めましたきさん僕やり
ますはいこれ命かかりますけどやります僕
はなぜならいやこれしか生きる道がないの
でいやそんなことないでしょこれで死ねる
なら本も名誉もある程度確立してる状態で
こういう攻めたことする人って本当に行か
れてるすからねそういう人が本なんすよ分
僕そのなのかもいやすよいやそうなんです
よね結局もうすごすごいそこで落ち着い
たらもう俺は終わりだと思ってるん
でもどうしちゃったんだなんかついてん
じゃないですかここ死んでる数がちょっと
桁違いなんでここに座ってるだけであんま
良くないんすよ結局いやですよね多分骨が
大量にある中でであそこの掘りこたみたい
なスペースもあそこも掘れば多分出てくる
んですよそこのそのゼ距離の多分地下に
ゴーンってある井なんで四方発砲多分骨
だらけで下の骨分あれコンクで埋めたって
ことはある程度骨が露呈しちゃっててそれ
を隠したんだと思うんすよここにその囲ま
れた状態で入るこれ1ヶ月以上入った人い
ないいすから
ねなるほど
一旦さっきから1回闇やりますって言って
ちょっと考えさせてくださいっていうのを
ちょっと4回ぐらい繰り返しての話がやば
すぎて本当にどうにかなっちゃいそうジで
じゃ一旦ちょっと入ってみてから考えます
ね入って出れないいすよあれです
よこれかこれが闇色ですね闇色です失礼し
ます
うわあ
すげえこれですね
ふかきさんありがとうございましたそうす
ねそうねやばそうすね
やばいや
ばこれで入っちゃうってことですねこれ俺
しかおらんおら
んカやら
んいやマジすか
これいや本当にさんいやこれ気をつけて
ください絶対押さないで
くださいわないしょで殺すんすか
僕何
今
何落ちませんでした今
えなんか投げたなんか落ちたわ落ち
たやばいさっき
のなんか崩れた幼いでがフりになっちゃっ
た落ちましたよえマジで気をつけてくだい
気をつけます
お待ってこんな深いんですか
これやいね
すげえだ
はいこれ何これなんか白い胸だわ本
だこれおかしいっすよ
ねえなんすかそれどこが光ってるんですか
一いやもうパッとやった方がいいかもしれ
ないですねですねじゃおります番下
までうわあ
これかじゃはを抜きますよ
はいさまずむね
[拍手]
はいじゃ僕とサベさんは本当に帰ります
はいありがとうございますさ何があったら
電話するからなるべく本当に出しできて
ほしいうん分かりましたでこれ絶対約束
するんすけど僕たちがいたずらしたり連絡
なくガラガラって入ってくることないで
連絡も何もないのにガラガラって聞こえ
たらもう警察呼んじゃっていいかもしれ
ないです分かりました例的なのの可能性も
あるすけど了解ですうんいいんすねやるん
すねやりますオ
す出ははいお願いしますではよいスタート
出ますね
はい
15分間始まりまし
た
本当に真っ暗
です
なけ
寒い何もの
H
なんか叩い
てる
何
やばい精神的に
きついなんか音聞こえる
めっちゃ
やばい
思い出せエレクトリカル
パレードエレクトリカルパレード
エレクトリカル
パレードディズニーシ行きたいランドでも
いい女のことでいき
たい
長い
よ長い
よ
ん
えなんか今動きうめき声みたい
な
は
マジか
よ背中触られた
多分
あああ
あ終わった終わりまし
た15分経過しまし
た出れないんだよなえ聞こえてたかな
うめき声聞こえたんだよな
うってやつ入ってたらいいけどなんでも
いいから来てくれ助け
てね本当早く来てくれないと
[音楽]
やばい
怖いはじめさん助けてあよかったなとか
生きとるぞよかった失はしてないみたいで
や
ばいどうも